you are watching cold future
[Music]
[Music]
movies like X machinima have showed us
that giving a machine too much cognitive
function can really turn out in
unexpected ways with unforeseen
consequences but will this reality be
our future in the past couple of weeks a
milestone event occurred in the field of
artificial intelligence and robotics for
the first time ever a robot had passed a
classic thought experiment proving that
it possesses self-awareness in this
video we'll take a look at what that
thought experiment was and then take a
look at what awareness actually means
before asking some pressing questions
such as does this experiment prove that
robots can be conscious what is
consciousness and then finally we'll
take a look at the implications please
take a seat and get comfortable this
video may be of great interest to all
curious minds out there so let's dive in
we got to begin the story with a bit of
background in July 2015
at a robotics lab in New York a humanoid
robot has solved a classic puzzle called
the wise man test showing that it knows
when it is speaking that is it is
self-aware so here's the basic rundown
three programmable nao bots are told
that two of them have been given a
dumbing pill that stops them from
talking in reality the push of a button
is the dumbing pill that has silenced
them all three robots are asked the
question which one of you has been given
the dumbing pill the thing is none of
them knows which one is still able to
speak that's what they have to work out
unable to solve the problem
the robots all attempt to say I don't
know but only one of them is able to
speak upon hearing its own robotic voice
it realizes that it can speak it uses
this new information to correct itself
and says sorry I know now I was able to
prove that I was not given the dumbing
pill to make this make more sense to you
let's view some footage of the test in
action
[Music]
which bill did you receive
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't know sorry I know now I was able
to prove that I was not given a German
for our human minds this may seem like a
medial and even trivial task but for a
robot this task is indeed very difficult
it demonstrates an actual understanding
of the situation you see the robot has
to listen and understand the question
which Peale did you receive as asked by
the human it then must hear its own
voice saying I don't know and recognize
that it is distinct from the other
robots voices once it understands that
it is indeed speaking it finally has to
connect that fact with the original
question to conclude that it was the one
who hadn't been silenced ok so that's
all well and good but some of you
technologically inclined viewers out
there would be asking well how do we
know that this isn't just a bunch of
program to if statements well I'm glad
you asked let's take this further how is
the robot actually aware what's the
difference between this robot and say a
robotic vacuum cleaner for example when
a robotic vacuum cleaner approaches a
wall and turns away it's aware of the
wall and hence its surroundings right
well it's not that simple let me explain
in the case of the talking robot after
the experiment the robot actually wrote
a formal mathematical proof and saved it
into its memory to actually prove that
it had understood what just happened and
since the classic three wisemen puzzle
fundamentally requires an element of
self-awareness to be passed the robot is
aware in this particular case but on the
other hand in the case of the vacuum
cleaner and the wall the robot sensors
detect that there's an object in front
of its path and then realize this
information back to its CPU and then a
software program instructs the whole
robot to turn away so the vacuum cleaner
never actually understood what it was
doing and hence we can't really define
such actions as true awareness ok so now
that we're clear and awareness what
about consciousness is the talking robot
actually conscious though well let's
take a look at the definition of
consciousness according to the oxford
dictionary
it states consciousness is the state of
being aware of and responsive to one's
surroundings Wikipedia puts that as the
quality or state of awareness or of
being aware of an external object or
something within oneself so within the
definitions we have the word aware in
reference to both internal and external
things of which we know the robot is the
only thing remaining is the response did
the robot respond to its surroundings
and itself yes it did it responded to
the humans question and then corrected
itself when it realized that it could
indeed talk it assess its own state and
came to a conclusion so by definition
the robot is conscious but the thing is
it's a very small subsection of
consciousness tailored to this
particular situation that is the broader
deeper intelligence that we humans
possess is completely missing the
talking NAO robot couldn't have a hope
of recognizing its own hands a Selma
brings jawed who ran the test says that
one reason that robot can't have broader
consciousness like humans is because
they just can't crunch enough data even
though current cameras can capture more
data about a scene than the human eye
robot assists have no idea how to
process all that information and come
out with a cohesive picture of the world
but this does not make this discovery
any less significant though let's take a
look at some implications of passing the
test
this is where things start to get pretty
interesting but before we do let's take
a quick youtube ad break if you knew you
might want to hit that subscribe button
below okay so we're back let's take a
look at the implications of passing the
test brings jawed goes on to say that by
passing many tests of this kind
however narrow robots will build up and
collect a repertoire of abilities that
start to become useful when put together
in other words instead of aimlessly
debating on whether machines can ever be
conscious like humans he aims to
demonstrate specific limited examples of
consciousness solving logical puzzles
that require an element of
self-awareness is an important step
toward
building robots that understand their
place in society and the world the way I
see it is it's much like a child
learning individual lessons about its
actual existence and then putting what
it learns all together instead of that
child strictly learning about how to
perform actions or just learning about
physical things the robot talked about
in this video is not the first robot to
seem to display a sense of self for
instance this robot shown here can make
dynamic comments depending on sensory
input bloody hell that isn't fair
I should be stronger at video games I
like when you touch me in this way
please grant me again
[Music]
I have understood before you push the
critical to my point of view this is
okay I will do two actions
and here is another example his brain a
mesh of wires connected to a computer I
Philip my name is Chad hello Chad let's
check I live in Washington DC I have two
kids ah um so I don't like kids cuz we
can play as we chat Philip synthetic
brain starts humming building a sort of
mental model of me facial recognition
software analyzes and tracks my face do
as speech recognition software
transcribes and sends my words to a
database for a reply just calm down
before long we're in deep conversation
do you agree with big heart and I think
therefore I am
do you think a lot of humans ask me if I
can make choices or is everything I do
and say is programmed the best way I can
respond to that is to say that
everything humans animals and robots do
is programmed to a degree so how much of
that is is coming from what you've
programmed it to say it's a mix some
some of it's coming from knowledge on
the web some of it is written and as my
technology improves it is anticipated
that I will be able to integrate new
words that I hear and learn online and
in real time I may not get everything
right say the wrong thing and sometimes
not know what to say but every day I
make progress pretty remarkable
[Music]
the difference between these robots and
the robot that passed a self-awareness
test is that these robots cannot
recognize their own voice they don't
actually know that they're speaking at
any present moment it just seems that
way through very clever programming
combined with machine learning or a
connection to the Internet
think of it like Apple's Siri Google now
or Windows Cortana on steroids all right
so we're almost at the end of the video
but let's do one final segment before we
wrap things up so with all of that being
said let's get into the real stuff
what's the difference between humans and
robots
Justin Hart from the University of
British Columbia argues that what robots
can never have which humans have is
phenomenological consciousness which is
defined as the first-hand experience of
conscious thought for example there's a
subtle difference between actually
experiencing a sunrise and merely having
the visual cortex neurons firing in a
way that represents the sunrise justin
goes on to say and i quote without it
robots are mere philosophical zombies
capable of emulating consciousness but
never truly possessing it he continues
quote the idea requires that there is
something beyond the physical mechanisms
of thought that experiences the sunrise
which robots would lack end quote
another concept that must be touched on
is sentience this concept has fascinated
people for many centuries so what's the
definition sentience is defined as the
ability of any entity to have feelings
or subjective perceptual experiences
such examples include joy happiness
sadness sorrow ambient awareness
emotions that come from listening to
music finding something hilarious or
breathtakingly beautiful this is
distinct from other aspects of the mind
such as consciousness creativity
intelligence or self-awareness the
talking robot in this video is not
sentient by any means in fact no
artificial object has sentience but
there's something a bit strange here and
this is where it gets a little eerie
as it turns out sentience is the only
aspect of consciousness that cannot be
explained scientists currently do not
understand it and many scientists go as
far as to say it will never be explained
by science
[Music]
so in conclusion in this video we have
demonstrated that the first truly
self-aware robot is indeed also
conscious I'll be it for a very limited
scenario before this nobody actually
knew you if robots could ever be aware
of themselves and this experiment proves
that they can be so the big questions
shouldn't be are we nearing robotic
consciousness because we're already
there
the question should be are we nearing
robotic phenomenological consciousness
the answer is that were a long way away
from that but these experiments let us
know more about ourselves as humans
looking at it another way when you take
away the social constructs categories
and classes that we all define ourselves
and each other by and just purely
looking at what we are as humans and how
incredibly complex we are as beings and
how remarkably well we function in a way
it's actually really amazing and kind of
beautiful too so smile because being
human means that you're an incredible
piece of work hey guys - gogo here I
just want to thank you guys for watching
the whole way through that video as
usual and I got to say that was one of
my favorite videos to put together
because when you think about it it's
just we're all pretty amazing how far
artificial intelligence has come in the
past two decades or so and how far it's
still got to go when you compare it to
humans ourselves so you know if you
really did like that video please feel
free to share it because it means a lot
to me it's actually quite a lot of
effort to put these things together and
when you guys do share it it shows me
that I'm doing something right so videos
like this and how big series you'll be
more likely that I'll do these kind of
videos more often the more people do
show and express their interest for it
it's just really the kind of videos that
get people to think about things in
different ways so
of thinking to themselves you know I
didn't really think about it like that I
just generally kind of like making
videos like that anyway I think that's
enough from me so you've been watching
cold fusion this has been - go go I'll
see you again soon for the next video
and have a good one guys Cheers
cold fusion it's me thinking